[Music]
tell me how this collaboration with
NatGeo came about do you call them do
they call you they called me I got an
email basically saying that NatGeo is
looking for a musical piece to be
composed by me that doesn't necessarily
sound like me so it was more about me
composing a piece for something that
Darren Aronofsky directed and I'm a big
Darrin or not to be fan so immediately I
saw that name Zedd teaming up a National
Geographic on their new series from
director Darren Aronofsky one strange
Rock and hosted by Will Smith
what makes this track different than the
typical Zedd track it is very different
I've always been I can't I come from
classical music so this is much more in
line with what I used to do 20 years ago
20 years ago when you were 8 I started
when I was 4 so even more than that oh
yeah oh my gosh
so um I wrote a motive just like in
classical music that the entire song is
based on it doesn't have a chorus or a
verse or a bridge for vocals or lyrics
or anything and you know how Darren
oftentimes the zooms into things really
detailed and showcases it from a
different perspective that's kind of how
I built the track and the 28 year old DJ
shot the video at a pretty historic spot
in Los Angeles up to the cave
I heard that you were in the original
Batcave which is kind of Awesome yeah
it's crazy it's right around the corner
I didn't even know it was here it was
really awesome I got to play piano in
this cave that was projected with images
from the documentary I was kind of just
in the middle of this changing
environment which was really beautiful
and you know combined where the music
was really powerful
[Music]